à la sortie du tribunal
une centaine de gilets jaunes poing levé
au soutien trois des leurs parmi eux
frédéric vuillaume une des figures du
mouvement à besançon
c'est clair que c'est un procès
politique puisque ya un acharnement sur
notre famille sur kevin donc voila et en
fin de compte en plus on a on n'a jamais
cassé quelque chose on n'a jamais rien
fait par rapport à ça la justice
reproche aux trois gilet jaune d'avoir
crié à plusieurs reprises castaner
assassin c'était le 13 mars dernier le
ministre de l'intérieur inaugurer un
commissariat de police
des mots proférés à distance que le
ministre n'a sans doute pas entendu pour
l'avocat des gilet jaune il ne s'agit
pas d'un outrage l'expression n'est pas
à prendre au premier degré personne ne
dit que monsieur castaner est un
assassin il s'agit d'interpeller certes
vivement la cité nous tous sur un
certain nombre de comportements
assassine ton la démocratie assassine
temps la liberté d'expression c'est un
slogan et c'est à mon sens non pas
injurieux et encore moins outrageant
c'est juste un slogan qui doit nous
interpeller
ce procès s'est déroulé sans la
personnes offensées
christophe castaner qui n'étaient pas
représentés non plus par un avocat
dans cette affaire c'est le parquet de
besançon qui a décidé de poursuivre
c'est important aujourd'hui de montrer
qu'il y avait une atteinte à la
démocratie et qu'il fallait absolument
être là parce qu'en fin de compte c'est
que des slogans qu'on a balancé tirerait
pas ce slogan non non on l'entend
partout en france et je vois jeunes dans
les manifestations et je vois pas
pourquoi trois personnes passent au
tribunal aujourd'hui pour le même slogan
qu'on entend tout le temps partout sur
deux les gilets jaunes ont repris en
choeur l'oph ans où le slogan selon le
point de vue le tribunal a préféré
sagement mettre le jugement en délibéré
à quelques heures du défilé du 1er mai